[applaudissements]
tout dans ce monde
J'ai laissé mon trésor là-bas dans la mer
Trouve le
[applaudissements]
que ferez-vous
Aimerais-tu te joindre à moi?
Est-ce une panne ?
Pourquoi voudriez-vous être un pirate? C'est génial.
depuis
brise marine
[applaudissements]
parfum de sel
bons amis
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Des pirates. Nous sommes les Pirates au Chapeau de Paille.
[musique]
Allons à Grand Line
Eaux très dangereuses, grandes îles
C'est le grand pirate, et il y a One Piece.
Nous nous faisons des ennemis partout où nous allons
Prends-le.
Ils sont venus après toi.
[musique]
C'est moi, je t'ai sauvé
Je suis idiot de leur avoir pardonné à tous les deux.
[musique]
Si nous étions cet ami
je peux tout faire
[musique]
Je vais tuer mes amis d'un seul coup, alors merci.
pensée
tu es mon capitaine
Jusqu'au dernier
[musique]
je vais t'épater
Je ne pardonnerai jamais à quiconque blesse mes amis.
[musique]
Qu'a-t-il de si spécial ?
Je m'appelle Monkey D. Luffy
L'homme qui deviendra le roi des pirates
[musique]
C'est terrible qu'il y ait autant de pirates.
C'est mon visage.